ce n'est pas je crois faire de la
polémique que de dire que la lutte anti
terroriste n'est pas précisément encore
de votre programme
on a relevé une mesure néanmoins nous
allons vous voulez constituer un corps
de vigiles privés
est ce que c'est à la hauteur de l'enjeu
ou est-ce que vous considérez que nous
avons un arsenal de mesures suffisant
pour lutter contre le terrorisme
aujourd'hui alors j'apprends que je veux
constituer un corps de vigiles privés je
sais pas où vous avez lu ça sur votre
site je les ai mis deux reprises elle
n'existe que dans votre poche à dire et
veiller à ce que j'ai à dire dans
pardonnez moi monsieur mais nous n'avons
pas inventé cette mesure des vigiles
privés pour surveiller les centres
commerciaux équipés d'armes non létales
nous l'avons lu il ya deux ans des
maniaques bennahmias 2001 dans fait les
surprises quand on fait des choses sur
internet c'est l'heure du tout bio dont
quatre membres a écrit le songe est
beaucoup plus important je voudrais
mesdames yes je voudrais me féliciter et
je le dis sans aucune démagogie de la
façon dont le président de la république
dont le premier ministre manuel valls
dont bernard cazeneuve dont jean yves le
drian et l'ensemble du gouvernement
l'ensemble des forces de police
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
or vigiles même si un travail utile ont
réagi par rapport à la situation
incroyable d'assassinât d'attentats que
nous avons vécu la façon dont même la
gestion de l'état d'urgence a été mis en
place montrent que nous sommes
réellement république est en démocratie
car le droit de manifestation étaient
toujours autorisées
ça s'est vu de nombreuses fois car les
libertés publiques ont été tout à fait
légèrement totalement autorisée est donc
dans ce cadre là je le dis et je la
firme
il n'y a pas beaucoup de gouvernements
de chefs d'état de premier ministre qui
aurait réagi de la même manière